it's time for roses and Rosie in
paradise with the Tiki relevant drinking
you guys oh my god the season premiere
of bachelor in paradise or should we
call it scheduler in paradise because it
was all about chat and that's not bad
I'm not complaining it was kind of a
train wreck let's talk about it I'm
gonna say we need to divide this into
four tiers of the discussion tier number
one the meet-and-greet
so during this we had Canadian Daniels
return and I gotta say he's freaking
funny I don't know if I want to be
associated with herpes but we also had
Evans return here we are we're gonna
attach baggage and I gotta say he's not
that funny but the producers probably
told him to go through Chad's luggage
which was pretty funny
bottom line Chad came back and you
brought a meat scale a meat scale yeah
tier number two the make-out session
this is what everybody starts literally
making out Chad and lace two crazies
don't make a right they make a wrong and
it's great television are you so Chad
and lace started making out and then we
got to Tier three already I know we're
moving through them quickly it's cuz a
lot happens in four in Tier three it was
a lot of pushing each other and being
like you wanna Europe Europe but then
their tongues would meet that was always
happening shut up you're not being the
lace I know right now you don't know her
you've known her for an hour you've
enjoyed for all of it and they were
turned on yet offended offended is what
takes us to tier for the morning after
you guys there's no other way to say
this chat pants
so that's something that's never
happened in bachelor nation before
cheers to Chad for being new and
different I didn't know it was possible
at this point mm-hmm yeah and that was
after just lots of Chad being super
offensive saying really mean things to
spare up telling her to you know I'll
let the Chad speak for itself
his son so he said a bunch of mean
things and then I guess overnight he
eats himself on the beach and the other
cast members retold that story
Chad woke up wondered why he was naked
and then came out super hungover and
kind of unclear on whatever was so mad
if I don't rig this carefully it will
bludgeon me in the eyes drink carefully
advice to Chad to sum up to sum up just
sum up all the contestants are gathered
and Chris Harrison makes his move and
says Chad I'm gonna have to ask you to
leave you gotta go you were rude to the
contestants you were rude to the staff
Chad doesn't really remember any of it
and chad is told to leave paradise after
Chad told me he was gonna top himself
and you know what he did actually bottom
himself out on the beach drunk so drunk
passed out not conscious pooping his own
pants or maybe swimsuit I don't know
what are you wearing paradise bottom
line he woke up naked
Chad then freaks out even watch the show
and says you know that he wasn't given a
chance Chad said he has nothing nothing
in my life yells at Chris Harrison you
get this feeling like maybe he's being
used by the reality TV machine but as a
reminder nobody else their pants yeah I
will defend Chad but I will also call
chat out this looks worse doesn't it so
we ended on a cliffhanger of sorts
Chad was told to go home no no no it
looks like he comes back which is
exactly what he did on the Bachelorette
a 2.0 situation where Chad's kicked off
and then he returns so what did you guys
think of the premiere please let me know
on Twitter I
I have so much rose' in this Tiki thing
I'm not sure this is gonna work all
season
it just holds so much thanks so much for
watching guys and make sure to Oh like
et Facebook page subscribe to us on
YouTube and follow me on Twitter I'm at
Lauren see my probably too special about
your it up days and to find out if I'm
drunk in the middle of it god I feel so
feminine with this in yeah something new
and different for me